this hit me during the 3 days where the
news was talking about me and a racist
tie raid from a comedian or whatever
however they labeled it during a comedy
show from a roast comedian to a comedian
that I knew granted they you know tried
to betray me and like get famous from an
incident but I always said if it was if
I said what I said to that comedian to
an Uber driver and that video came out
of me going da
right that I would apologize for that
would be me losing my temper and my mind
for a second and doing that so what
would I do the same thing that I did for
real life for something that I did at a
comedy show does this make sense have
you talked to that com comic sense no I
tried to talk to him immediately you
know and he kept doing news things and
media things saying Tony hasn't tried to
apologize Tony hasn't reached he's just
lying through his teeth literally I have
messages you know and me reaching out to
other friends that I knew knew him
because I literally wanted to be like
dude what are you doing this is crazy
like I've taken you on the road to open
for me before like what is happening it
it's a very weird situation it was a
very very interesting one because he had
no real reason to do that and in
my my little bit of a conspiracy
theorist opinion I think it uh I think
he was perhaps motivated to do it by
perhaps exterior forces who knows oh
yeah but
maybe International exterior forces if
that makes sense based on anything or
this is purely conspiracy theory no
pretty much based on um well what's in
here we go so what's interesting is that
I woke up very early that morning to a
bunch of misspelled tweets and things
like that and I didn't know what was
going on and uh long story short I end
up trying to fish around to see where
these hundreds of very weird tweets that
are directly at me you know that say
like you [__] [__] suck you [__] of
Peace basically like Niche earlier like
all of these I'm like what is this what
are what is going on here right ni so I
reverse search and I end up finding um
articles in Chinese that uh that that
that said that a comedian made fun of
another comedian made fun of a Chinese
comedian and um the Chinese comedian was
offended and tweeted that he was
offended at what the comedian said and I
had to go through like Google translate
and everything and again this is at like
5: in the morning and they're talking
about this tweet that hadn't happened
yet literally so a few hours later the
Tweet happens and I'm like oh my
goodness this is really happening so
right then I started trying to reach out
to him because I could see like
something was up because it made the
news in China before it happened here do
this make sense yeah so it's not really
a conspiracy at all it's just such a big
deal that I don't want to make a big
deal about it does that make sense
yeah that's crazy yeah it is crazy and
there's no way that like he doesn't have
another Twitter or X or whatever like a
separate one in well here's another
interesting thing is that technically I
guess in China you're not really allowed
to be on Twitter you're not allowed to
say things on Twitter unless it's for
like a purpose so all those accounts had
zero followers zero tweets all these
things and the Bots but Chinese names
and chines this and you know it was very
blatantly like a wow yeah it was like a
coordinated attack that's scarier yeah I
know that's not getting canceled that's
getting targeted internationally that's
crazy that you if it is true that you
can be cancelled because just like
another entity or somewhere from another
country decides that you are going to be
the subject of cancellation 100% what
would be the reason for that that's kind
of like a modern day well again and I
don't know what we're going to leave in
this mama jama but now now we're
talking but what's interesting is that
at the time yeah they were being blamed
for covid they're being blamed for a lot
of humanitarian things that perhaps are
going on in a place as powerful as China
and I mean obviously ridiculously
powerful we're taught in history books
and whatnot that we're number one and
this and that you know but we're you
know they make everything they do a
lot anyway so I think it was a full out
um you know in today's modern world the
media and what people think especially
on the internet where Twitter makes the
story you know stories now start on
Twitter and pop culture is an easier way
to hit than fake news right so if they
did if they made me look like that then
they look like a victim and being being
the victim especially in May of 2021 was
like all the all the all the rage yeah
exactly so um I think it you
know I was part of that wow yeah wow
that's a that's really interesting I
know I know and I'm always like can I
leave it
in I think so Yoni what do you think
yeah yeah yeah there you go I'm not
going to edit this thanks thank
you that's really [__] interesting
yeah scary but it's scary even in the
context everything no I'm not I'm not I
avoid Tik Tok but it's scary in the
context of like literally everything in
life right now in social media in
general and how we could be fed
different things and algorithms and Bots
and I feel like it's kind of a mind [__]
and control you're 100% correct and uh
you know with that it's like if
something gets 5,000 likes and 6,000
likes within hours seven eight nine and
this tweet was going ballistic because
it it it had worldwide
traction um that is what journalists are
looking for now that is the new news
it's not go find a story it's not let's
listen to the wire whatever they used to
do back in the day it is literally okay
this thing's picking up steam on Twitter
this is a news story that's the the
world we live in now it's so weird it
used to be I get my news from Twitter
well now the news gets their news from
Twitter you know what I mean I do so if
something's blowing up and they don't
know here's the interesting thing if
something's blowing up on Twitter they
don't know where that blowing up is
coming from
so Bots humans working humans being told
what to do getting an alert on their
thing which we have no idea what's going
on over there you know so what type of
system or whatever they could be using
but I mean it was hundreds of tweets a
minute hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of I'm going to
kill you you're going to die it kind of
cracks me up when I hear someone get a
death threat oh I got a death threat
it's like you have no idea what I went
through during that I mean it was
literally thousands of
[Music]
them
I